hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay we
got a problem here with two these guys
being all a-holes about you know living
they need to just learn their place and
die like a lot of things in this world
but it is up to me to make sure that
they fulfill their destiny I don't know
I don't remember how many times if any I
shot them I'm just hoping that I can get
that you know at least figure out where
they are maybe I could just run past him
I'll try
we running oh that's not good
get Tom dad yeah Oh miss me oh that hurt
that that hurt okay
there seems to be a lot more than I
would be able to kill so let's try okay
not that apparently standing right there
all right there okay just try something
ah killed one okay but I wasted bullets
all right where is that one
aha found you got ya [ __ ] okay that was
two down I don't think I have enough
money ammo to take down that one but let
me try oh whoa bro bro bro bro
got it Wow tell me I did it but what did
I did
ah oh oh
huh what's this it's all this then just
gonna mow oh well I can hit you with my
ax can i maybe I can ha
nope nope not gonna try did I interrupt
your swing awesome if I did okay all
this more good thing they got this nice
handy countertop here hop no stop ah
burp it yeah prep dip ah what a hole how
could you
how can he slap how can she slap huh huh
huh got ya AHA come to join the party
I'll gonna get the jump on me this time
Oh boohoo missed Oh foo oh come on
nope yeah toward a ground
I would like to burn this whole place
down to the ground screw you I'm just
leaving him in there I don't care
there's one more in here come here come
on buddy call my buddy come on I'll buy
to get up out here
Oh missed me a whack-whack wonk wink and
bang
or shotgun ammo yes please reload this
alright keep the axe in here it's locked
okay there's still the head hand in
there
Oh can't get me whoa hello whoa that
thing is speedy um fine if I miss yeah I
miss all over the place whatever can't
get me too fast for you I saved too
often for you thought I might have been
a trash can or something like that then
I could crack it open get it ah it's you
but I can get you I can get you with
this up what I mean with the UH with the
uh this ah baloney okay come on I
usually do side strafing so it's easier
to do it this way whoa what was that I
saw it's all behind the kitchen table
but I'm worried about he's got a bit of
range on his attack he has to he's in
wheelchair Oh
oh come on oh come on oh yeah the corner
there we go
Pro getting good with this axe Oh
oh yeah reflexes like a cat cross with a
ninja could be a horrible horrible
amalgamation of terror I don't know how
much @ml have I collected on this gun I
know it keeps your mo with you so nope
none apparently all right Louie you know
let me give it a try the shotguns nice
but not that nice short-range easy to
miss whoa go down okay
that was weird I guess they really
didn't want you to miss that
okay I mean I would have gone down
eventually oh there is something in this
room I can tell he's coming in there
right there looks just like oh it's a
big spider doohickey probably a bust out
of the door or not oh oh not one of you
all right let's try this
actually let me use up the shotgun ammo
on this guy if we're gonna be like you
know smart about this
okay here we go honk-honk honk-honk
oh three shots really no way no way
that's baloney I mean I'm not gonna
complain about it but Oh battery I
almost missed that but that just totally
defies my previous experience oh okay
the machine pistol is actually pretty
powerful I don't need a I need a full
spray here basement I don't know what do
you want me go - oh what's in here
creepy picture hey button bunk oh what's
that
okay upstairs did that did that door
open up I don't know I don't know where
that was
yeah it did and then there's a big guy
in there
use the gun again use up the shotgun
ammo cuz I have it
well come on can't even get off the door
that's it I could probably have taken
care of him with the axe but ah c'est la
vie alright another button pistol ammo
whoa what was that I heard something
okay
that's green button probably the green
door downstairs I like this house huh
feel like I might have missed something
in here I'm getting the willies
okay here we go
Oh God come here come here come here
buddy come here there we go
little more right there miss me douche
mmm come on it's my slow-motion
execution like in Skyrim ah Moorhead ah
there we go
just as your head was exploding out of
your neck oh oh I don't like this it's
blood on the floor over there seems to
be just a closed room there's a way out
Oh like this huh
what the hell oh no not again ah [ __ ]
hell
die you [ __ ] there we go I think I got
it well I'm down to pistol ammo and even
that shotgun upstairs only had one shell
left so stick with this thoughts out
there I saw something there was
something there I saw it oh oh
oh that's that house back down past the
bow oh that's the house over there
before
I still don't like this I'm getting like
shivers up and down my spine
okay all right now why did that button
have to be all the way over here
what okay I'm leaving Rowan on my boat
don't tell me I'm gonna crash my boat or
something
ah dammit I forgot I forgot I totally
forgot ah [ __ ] hell
Dodge [ __ ] oh god why did I leave so
many I hate myself
damn you passed me up where do I go oh
here oh god they're after me
ah it's like Daisy running through the
woods hmm gotta be here gonna be here
there it is there it is there it is
please let me in I mean I've no health
left Oh God ah I probably could use my
axe for that guy
always got to be dark in here pills yes
please give me both can i crack this
open no oh there's lights thank you
lights Oh is there a light for the yes
there is okay hello how are you want me
to jump up on your kitchen table and
totally pone you bro walk walk those
shotgun shells they are Frick and frack
[ __ ] brought the shotgun I should have
brought the shotgun nothing under the
stairs oh is that blood on the walls but
not one of you again whoops Trey come on
bring it [ __ ] you ain't got nothing on
me hippie dick yeah okay what was up
here besides machine pistol ammo
okay I can't have been it oh boy oh boy
oh boy
hello did I miss something
there another door into the house
someone I can't about it there had to be
more must be missing something like this
door it's kind of bashed in but maybe on
the painting no up up no up top oh oh
out the window okay I got it I got it I
got it I got it
aah Oh Oh golly where the heck is that
oh is that back in the aah hey God get
me out let me out let me out let me out
yeah good uh okay ah damn it
uh-huh okay so have my pistol out when I
do this okay so apparently the window
was either boarded up or I was too
stupid to be able to go through it okay
you're there I go around you yeah ah
what the hell
come here come here dicks there we go
taken care of like a boss like get you
with my axe miss me miss me that's me
that's me that's me there we go
Oh another one I'm just going by screw
you screw you buddy I think I need to go
back back to the mansion Oh give me out
of these woods how did I even get in
these woods
I don't even remember oh yeah this is
back oh oh and here's a submachine gun
wait how much ammo did I have left here
why did I never pick this up is it
because I had the shotgun and I had too
much ammo okay I'll just switch okay I
can't get back that way I don't know I
don't know man maybe there was something
else in the house that I missed I mean
there had to be right oh all you I screw
you just forget you or maybe you're
guarding something I don't know
um no he wasn't guarding anything screw
that I'm not gonna waste the ammo on him
if I don't need to oh man I don't know
how to get back this way
what is this way go oh this way it goes
what Oh
wait where is this oh hello I screw you
am I going back the way I first came
towards the boat or am I going somewhere
new ow
fu now this is new this is got to be new
Wow whoa oh no no no no no screw you oh
you're like oh I know what you things
are get open I know that was a waste of
ammo but [ __ ] I have six health yeah
that guy was right behind me ah
holy hell okay um fireplace I don't know
where the fireplace was it's jam now why
weird it's jammed now okay privacy
screen picture of a door alright anyway
I'm out of time for this episode I found
a fireplace though so thank you
everybody for watching
and I hope you're enjoying let's play so
far and I will see you in the next part
bye bye